avant de commencer cette vidéo une
petite annonce rapide pour vous annoncer
que le projet trinax est en ligne il
s'agit d'une campagne de financement
participatif sur Ulule afin de récolter
suffisamment de fonds pour emmener mes
étudiants sud-africain sur le terrain et
leur apprendre les techniques de
fouilles paléontologique et de
prospection cette année nous faisons
cette campagne en collaboration avec
Valentine de sciences de comptoir et si
jamais la campagne est un succès nous
emmènerons Valentine avec nous pour
faire les fouilles en Afrique du Sud
dans le carreau si vous souhaitez en
savoir plus un lien est disponible en
description afin d'aller voir la page de
lire le descriptif du projet trinax et
si vous le souhaitez de faire un don ou
de partager le lien afin de faire
connaître le projet trinax autour de
vous merci d'avance pour votre soutien
soit en partageant soit en faisant une
donation bonne vidéo
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est Paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux on commence ce Paléo news avec
la crise Permien Trias la crise
permiatriaque c'est une crise
d'extinction de masse qui a eu lieu il y
a 252 millions d'années et qui a vu
s'éteindre on estime 90% des espèces qui
vivaient donc c'est l'extinction pendant
laquelle la vie a failli disparaître et
ça ne s'est produit que il y a 252
millions d'années c'est pas loin c'est
juste avant les dinosaures 252 millions
d'années et on a ce nouvel article paru
dans nitcher Communication donc quand
même une belle revue donc un nouvel
article d'une équipe très fortement
internationale avec des chercheurs
chinois sud-africains américains etc etc
cette équipe internationale qui démontre
donc qu'il y a du mercure dans les
dépôts de la de la crise perméatrice
partout dans le monde et notamment en
Afrique du Sud alors le mercure c'est un
élément qui est relativement rare c'est
pas un élément qui est inexistant non
plus mais c'est un élèvement qui est
relativement rare et qui se promène pas
beaucoup et en fait on pense que enfin
on a constaté dans l'hémisphère Nord en
tout cas qu'il y avait un pic de mercure
dans les dépôts de mer dans les dépôts
sédimentaires de l'hémisphère Nord il y
a un pic de mercure qui correspond à
l'éruption des trappes de Sibérie vous
connaissez les trappes de Sibérie c'est
ce dont on pense que enfin les traps
déjà ce sont des coulées volcaniques
gigantesques c'est pas un seul volcan
qui a fait ça c'est vraiment une
activité volcanique titanesque des
millions de mètres cubes de lave dégagé
sur des sur des milliers de kilomètres
au carré des épaisseurs titanesques on
parle de kilomètres d'épaisseur de lave
qui se dépose quand on parle de traps et
donc c'est traps de Sibérie on pense
qu'ils ont dégagé suffisamment de CO2
suffisamment de polluants de manière
générale pour avoir provoqué
l'extinction de la fin du de la fin du
Permian donc l'extinction permet un
Trias donc cette trappe de Sibérie ils
ont aussi libéré du mercure et le
mercure comme j'ai dit c'est un élément
qui se balade pas beaucoup c'est un
élément qui qui est relativement rare
généralement dans ce sur la croûte
terrestre va dans la croûte terrestre et
encore plus dans les sédiments et il y a
donc plusieurs équipes de recherche
notamment de l'hémisphère Nord et en
Chine en particulier qui avait constaté
qu'au niveau de la limite permienrias et
bien on avait une espèce d'excursion de
mercure c'est à dire un pic de
production et de sédimentation de
mercure qui avait lieu au niveau de la
limite permienrias en coïncidence on va
dire avec justement ces éruptions de
trappes de Sibérie et la d'extinction de
masse qui avait lieu à la même époque
donc il semblait évident dans
l'hémisphère Nord au moins que
l'extinction de masse qui avait lieu à
la fin du Permien était lié à l'éruption
des trappes mais c'était pas encore
évident dans l'hémisphère sud et
notamment en Afrique du Sud je vous
rappelle qu'il y a que deux endroits où
on voit réellement bien la limite
permienrias il y a deux endroits où il y
a des coupes stratigraphiques à travers
la limite permienrias c'est la Chine et
l'Afrique du Sud en Chine c'est en dépôt
marin et en Afrique du Sud c'est en
dépôt terrestre donc la fameuse
extinction des gorgonopsia des paris
Azor et le l'apparition des listes aux
Russes l'apparition de de la radiation
adaptative des signaux d'homptes tout ce
qui s'est passé du coup à cette limite
permienrias et bien ça n'était pas
réellement directement corrélé avec les
trappes de Sibérie et il y avait
d'ailleurs une énorme discussion sur
quel âge avait cette limite patrias en
Afrique du Sud certains disaient qu'elle
était du même âge que l'extinction qui a
lieu en Chine et donc elle aurait été en
même temps que l'éruption et d'autres
disaient que non en fait ce qu'on voit
le turnover le changement de faune qu'on
observe en Afrique du Sud l'extinction
des parts des gorgonesiens et
l'apparition de lysosaurus du coup cette
ce grand changement phonique pour
certains il avait lieu avant la limite
permet un Trias donc il y avait des bas
et bien là cet article nous propose
maintenant une section enfin plusieurs
sections à travers
l'Afrique du Sud à travers la limite
permettrie à son Afrique du Sud et ce
qu'ils ont pu voir du coup c'est que il
y a effectivement une excursion de
mercure juste à l'endroit où on
positionne la limite Permien Trias
c'est-à-dire dans la palinklouf member
donc le membre pas l'inclouf de la
formation balfort en Afrique du Sud
ce qui veut dire et bien que c'est la
première fois
qu'on trace une corrélation directe une
corrélation au sens géologique c'est la
première fois qu'on trace une
corrélation directe entre
l'extinction qui se produit dans le
milieu terrestre en Afrique du Sud et le
volcanisme de Sibérie avant ça c'était
une hypothèse vous voyez et c'est là que
c'est super intéressant c'est que tous
ces scénarios catastrophes que vous avez
pu voir dans les documentaires où on
vous explique l'éruption volcanique qui
déclenche des alors qui éjectent du CO2
du coup il y a réchauffement de
l'atmosphère qui du coup libère
l'éclatrate qui est réchauffe encore
plus l'atmosphère et les espèces
suffoques et le soufre et les pluies
acides et les machins et tout tout ça
c'était de la spéculation
de la spéculation relativement
rationnelle relativement basé sur quand
même des données qui existaient mais il
n'y avait jamais eu de liens directs
tracés entre l'éruption d'un côté en
Russie et l'extinction des gorgonopsiens
des
partsaurus en Afrique du Sud
ce lien n'avait jamais été fait et ben
maintenant grâce au mercure mercure qui
est donc produit par les volcans le
mercure qui est très rare par ailleurs
mais qui est ici on le suppose produit
par les volcans et bien grâce à ce
mercure produit par les volcans
maintenant on a un lien direct entre le
volcanisme sibérien et l'extinction qui
a lieu en Afrique du Sud et donc
maintenant ce n'est plus de la
spéculation de dire ok c'est bien il y a
bien un truc lié au volcanisme qui s'est
produit et qui correlle en Afrique du
Sud avec la crise d'extinction de masse
donc vous voyez le turnover de faune il
a lieu ici donc dans la formation
Balfour entre au milieu de la panique
même beurre et ici vous avez le début de
la zone alystrosaurus donc le début du
Trias et ici vous avez la fin de la zone
où on trouve les abdos qui phallus mais
aussi les gorgonopsiens les paris Azor
qui est la fin du permis et donc à 250
millions d'années environ vous avez
cette excursion
cette excursion de mercure et vous avez
aussi ce changement de faune donc cette
étude elle est super intéressante parce
qu'elle tisse finalement un vrai lien
entre l'éruption et l'extinction mais
surtout elle vous illustre que avant ça
et ben c'était des scénarios basés sur
de la spéculation rationnelle et vous
imaginez on est en 2023 depuis combien
de temps vous entendez parler de la
ligne de la fin du permis depuis combien
de temps vous entendez parler de
l'extinction de tous ces animaux et
depuis combien de temps est-ce qu'on
vous dit c'est les traps de Sibérie qui
ont provoqué cette extinction
réfléchissez à depuis combien de temps
on vous parle de ça et maintenant
rendez-vous compte qu'on est en 2023 et
que c'est la première fois qu'on tisse
un lien direct entre les traps de
Sibérie avec l'extinction de la fin du
Permien moi ça me défonce moi ça m'a mis
en PLS on reste dans les extinctions de
masse avec l'extinction de la fin de
leur devicien une autre des grosses
extinctions de masse je vous rappelle
qu'il y a 5 grandes extinctions de masse
faire ordre vicia fin des vonyas fin
Permien fin Trias et fin Crétacé c'est
les 5 grandes extinction de masse et
bien vous avez un nouvel article dans
trends in écology an evolution donc ça
encore une fois un journal très
prestigieux
encore une fois écrit par une équipe
relativement internationale quoi que
essentiellement européenne et donc cet
article nous parle de la crise de la fin
de leur devicien donc une des cinq
grandes extinction de masse et nous dit
en somme que cette crise de la fin de
leur devicien
ben elle a pris quand même 10 millions
d'années vous voyez que là vous avez la
diversité en termes d'espèces ici la
diversité en termes de genre et ici la
diversité en termes de genre mais
estimée à partir d'une autre base de
données donc vous avez la base de
données de race muce vous avez la base
de données de cette cause qui
et donc ils estiment finalement cette
baisse de diversité au niveau spécifique
au niveau générique avec plusieurs
façons différentes et en fait on voit
que entre le pic de diversité et le le
creux maximum de diversité il se déroule
pas moins de à peu près 10 millions
d'années enfin en tout cas environ 8
millions d'années et ça ça c'est immense
c'est immense c'est un pas de temps
absolument immense 10 millions d'années
une crise d'extinction de masse si vous
reprenez par exemple celle du Permien le
pas de temps il est d'environ un million
d'années en tout cas peut-être même un
petit peu moins que ça vous êtes à 251
ici vous êtes à 252 enfin 51.7 ici vous
êtes à 252.2 ici donc vous avez à pas de
temps d'à peu près 500 000 ans quoi 500
000 ans durant lesquels les phénomènes
de l'extinction se sont déroulés là on a
10 millions d'années c'est 20 fois plus
et du coup bah ça pose la question
est-ce qu'on est en train de regarder un
événement est-ce qu'on est en train de
regarder plusieurs événements est-ce
qu'il s'agit vraiment d'un événement de
manière générale donc ça ça pose
réellement la question de la réalité
finalement de cette crise d'extinction
de masse est-ce que on n'a pas pris ça
pour une crise d'extinction de masse
parce que on avait un pas de temps
notamment les études qui ont été faites
par cette cause qui
Rao pckowski avait un pas de temps
d'environ 7 millions d'années donc quand
on est à quasiment 8 10 millions
d'années enfin quand on a une extinction
qui est étalée sur 8 10 millions
d'années avec un pas de temps de 7
millions d'années bah en fait ça devient
un instantané au lieu d'avoir un long
décla sur 10 millions d'années on a un
pas de temps qui est instantané quoi sur
un donc c'est
cette étude là en fait elle remet en
question même la réalité de cette
extinction de masse et du coup on remet
aussi en question au passage les
facteurs qui ont pu la provoquer cette
extinction parce que vous pouvez
toujours discuter que c'est alors il y a
eu de tout pour ça il y a eu la
météorite il y a eu le refroidissement
le réchauffement il y a eu le il y a eu
la Super Nova on a eu pour la fin de
leur devicien on a eu tout un tas de
d'hypothèses qui ont et du volcanisme
évidemment et donc on a eu tout un tas
d'hypothèses qui ont été proposées pour
tenter d'expliquer cette crise
d'extinction de masse des explications
qui peuvent s'expliquer sur un pas de
temps de 8 à 10 millions d'années il y
en a pas beaucoup
mais on a pas beaucoup bon là en
l'occurrence il privilégie un volcanisme
mais on sait qu'on a eu une grosse
période de froid à ce moment-là qui
n'est pas forcément en tout cas un
moment de de ces dans un intervalle de
ces de ces 8 10 millions d'années on
sait qu'on a eu une grosse période de
froid donc c'est pas vraiment cohérent
avec du volcanisme qui a plutôt tendance
à relâcher du CO2 mais en tout cas ce
qui est absurde c'est que waouh ça remet
pas mal de choses en question on reste
dans leur deviciens avec un nouveau site
qui a été découvert au Pays de Galles au
Royaume-Uni publié dans nightcher
écology and evolution encore une revue
prestigieuse une équipe encore une fois
internationale et différente des deux
précédentes mais qui nous racontent en
somme la même chose et en l'occurrence
bah que on est à leur domicile
donc on est très très loin de
l'explosion cambrienne maintenant on a
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'années
de l'explosion cambrienne et pourtant
dans cette ordovicien daté par graptolit
les graves tolites c'est l'unité de
mesure c'est le fossile
biostratigraphique du palais ozoïque
alors les graves tonits permettent quand
même une très fine résolution
biostratigraphique donc la datation hors
de vie c'est un moyen on peut lui faire
confiance et donc dans ces dépôts datés
solidement du milieu de leur devicien
grâce à ses grade tolites et bien il
trouve une faune qui ressemble
étrangement à celle du burgès qui date
du cambriand donc plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'années avant ça qui date de
ce qu'on appelait de ce qu'on appelle
l'explosion cambrienne donc vous avez
ici un truc qui ressemble à OPA bigna
ici vous avez un truc qui ressemble à
anomalo charis on reconnaît bien là les
espèces de crochets de anomalocaris on
reconnaît bien le corps segmenté
d'anomalocaris on retrouve des vers qui
ressemblent au vert qu'on retrouve en
abondance
au schiste de burgès bref on retrouve
une faune là vous voyez vous voyez cette
faune ici reconstruite on retrouve une
faune qui ressemble en a même des
crustacés bivals comme on en a dans le
schiste de burgesses donc ouais vous
voyez une faune qui ressemble à si
méprendre à celle de burgès mais alors
devicien
et du coup ça vous fait vous poser la
question mais du cette faune de burgès
en fait combien de temps elle a duré
parce que d'habitude on associe la faune
de burgès à burgès un genre de
photos en fait du cambriage inférieur
ceux qui s'y connaissent le plus se
rappelleront qu'il y a la même faune
presque à chaque jambe qui est un peu
plus vieille que les chiffres de
burgesses mais en réalité cette faune de
burgès elle s'est perpétuée pendant très
très longtemps y compris jusqu'à leur
domicien et en réalité faut savoir aussi
par exemple que les trucs qui
ressemblent à anomalo kaaris on en
retrouve jusqu'au dernier donc voici
schinder rannès Bart Lezy c'est un
animal de la même famille que
anomalocaris les radios donc enfin c'est
le même ordre on va dire que anomal
aucun risque l'ordre des radios donc et
il a vécu au début du dévonia donc en
fait cette faune de Burget ça le sait
pas du tout éteinte juste après burgès
elle s'est perpétuée pendant des
millions d'années après ça donc encore
encore une fois ça sa questionne
réellement le côté est-ce qu'il y a
réellement eu une explosion cambrienne
et d'ailleurs quand on regarde les
analyses génétiques et bien on constate
que les groupes qui sont qui
apparaissent pour la première fois dans
le registre fossile dans durant ce qu'on
appelle l'explosion cambrienne en fait
leur gêne par horloge moléculaire nous
donne une origine beaucoup plus ancienne
d'après les analyses génétiques ces
groupes devraient être beaucoup plus
anciens que ça jusqu'à 800 millions
d'années au lieu des 500 millions
d'années que nous propose le schiste de
burlesque donc c'est
cette série d'articles en fait elle est
assez assez ouf parce que elle remet en
question vraiment quelque chose qui
semble être fondamentalement accepté
mais en fait ne l'est pas du tout c'est
la réalité même de l'explosion
cambrienne et la réalité même de la
crise de la fin de leur devicien et moi
je trouve ça absolument oufissime on
reste dans le Paléozoïque et maintenant
on parle du monstre de Tully le monstre
de Tully c'est un enfin c'est pas un
fossile ce sont des fossiles parce qu'on
leur a pas retrouvé qu'un mais qui
ressemble à ça donc le cucul il est de
ce côté là la tête elle est de ce
côté-là on pense que la boue bouche elle
était au bout de la trompe et on pense
que le cucul c'est une nageoire et c'est
à peu près tout ce qu'on peut vous dire
du monstre de Tulip il s'appelle le
monstre de tulipe parce que à l'heure
actuelle on ne sait toujours pas quoi en
faire alors il y a quelques années était
sorti un article qui faisait du monstre
de Tully
impossible poisson parce qu'ils avaient
eu l'impression de voir des ossements à
l'intérieur et une organisation du
système nerveux et du système musculaire
qui semblait être cohérent avec un
poisson mais ce nouvel article qui a
utilisé des rayons X pour étudier le
monstre de Tully nous propose qu'en fait
bah non ils ont pas retrouvé les
structures en question ils ont pas
retrouvé des eaux ils ont pas retrouvé
les branchies ils ont pas retrouvé les
myomères donc l'organisation musculaire
typique des poissons
bref et surtout il y avait ils avaient
imaginé un genre de bras articulé dans
cette trompe en fait du monstre de Tully
donc bras articulé osseux qui semblaient
indiquer que c'était un poisson bah non
en fait pour eux c'est un simple
tentacules et si on a un tentacules on
n'a pas un poisson donc pour eux au
maximum le monstre de Tully c'est un
cordé donc un cousin des poissons mais
qui est toujours qui est toujours un
invertébré en l'occurrence qui n'est pas
encore invertébré mais pour eux en tout
cas le monstre de Tulip n'est pas un
poisson toujours au rayon les animaux
fantastiques et comment qu'on va les
classifier c'était la dance mystérieuse
qui comme son nom l'indique est un
mystère qui n'en est pas de temps
tellement hein puisque on a quand même
réussi à se rendre compte que c'était à
mosasaure un nouveau une nouvelle espèce
de mosasaure qui nous vient donc du
Maroc et qui a été décrit par une équipe
essentiellement européenne qui inclut
notamment
nouredding Jalil du Muséum d'histoire
naturelle de Paris et donc ce nouveau
mosasaure il a
[Musique]
et du coup bah c'est un mystère parce
que on ne sait pas ce qu'il mangeait on
ne sait pas d'où sortent ces carènes ni
ce qu'il mangeait vous voyez la taille
de l'animal en plus c'est pas un très
très gros mosasaure non plus donc de
quoi se nourrissait cette animal les
chercheurs proposent qu'il aurait pu se
nourrir de
vraiment être très spécialisé pour une
espèce de poisson ou pour une espèce de
céphalopodes donc de une espèce de de
pieuvre quoi
en l'occurrence peut-être d'ammonit
qui vraiment spécialisé dans un taxons
en particulier donc avoir des dents très
spécifiques pour un régime alimentaire
extrêmement spécifique après il y a peu
de chances d'après ce qu'ils disent les
dents et notamment les karennes sont
très délicates donc il y a peu de
chances que la bestiole se soit nourrie
de trucs très très durs donc si c'était
des ammonites c'était des ammonites à
coquilles très fines peut-être plutôt
des mollusques complètement mous
éventuellement probablement pas des
gastéropodes mais enfin voilà du coup on
ne sait pas
ce que mangeait Stella dance mais selon
ton est sûr c'est que c'est du jamais vu
donc c'est bel et bien une nouvelle
espèce et du coup son nom Stella dance
bah évidemment ça signifie la dent en
forme d'étoiles on continue avec les
gros animaux du Mésozoïque mais on passe
maintenant bien aux animaux terrestres
les dinosaures les donc les dinosaures
de la fin du Crétacé probablement plus
ou moins contemporain on va dire de
Stella dance cette nouvelle étude parue
dans la revue diversity et
essentiellement écrite par des
chercheurs français nous propose une
étude de la géochimie osseuse et
dentaire de certains dinosaures du
Crétacé de Sibérie donc voilà le Crétacé
de très très haut là-bas de très très
loin dans les hautes latitudes donc la
géochimie isotopique c'est la finalement
l'étude de la structure chimique des
ossements fossiles et cette structure
chimique en fait elle va nous renseigner
sur différents aspects de la biologie
des animaux notamment l'eau qu'il buvait
hello kill buvait va être plus ou moins
chargé en isotope lourd de l'oxygène en
fonction de à quel point il faisait sec
et à quel point il faisait et à quel
point il pleuvait alors c'est très
simple en Sibérie enfin dans les très
hautes latitudes et déjà à l'époque du
Crétacé les le climat était très
contrastés donc on avait une saison
sèche et on sèche et froide et une
saison humide et relativement plus
chaude donc ce qu'on appellerait l'hiver
et l'été respectivement et du coup
pendant l'hiver le lot s'évapore mais ce
n'est pas n'importe quelle eau qui va
s'évaporer c'est l'eau qui contient
l'élément isotopique l'oxygène
isotopique le plus léger donc l'oxygène
isotopique le plus léger s'évapore et
laisse derrière lui l'oxygène isotopique
le plus lourd et du coup l'eau de
boissons de nos dinosaures va être
chargée surchargé en isotope lourd de
l'oxygène c'est pas des isotopes
radioactifs vous en faites pas
c'est probablement pas ça qui les a tué
et donc en se basant sur cette
fragmentation isotope enrichissement en
isotope lourd en hiver et enrichissement
en isotope léger en été et en se basant
sur d'autres rapports isotopiques pas
seulement celui de l'oxygène ils ont
regardé plein de choses et ils ont ils
ont regardé par exemple le carbone aussi
donc ça vous donne à peu près les mêmes
signaux mais pas exactement de la même
façon le carbone ça va pas être lié à
l'eau de boisson mais plutôt à la
nourriture mais on va normalement
retrouver plus ou moins les mêmes
fragmentations isotopiques qui vont vous
donner plus ou moins les mêmes signaux
donc en regardant ça à la fois sur les
os et les dents mais aussi sur les
coquilles d'oeufs et bien on va savoir
quand est-ce que les coquilles d'oeufs
se sont formés en fait on va pouvoir
corréler la formation des coquilles
d'oeufs à la formation des eaux et on va
eux-mêmes les corréler à l'époque à
laquelle ils ont été formés à savoir
plutôt pendant le l'hiver pendant la
période sombre et la période sèche ou
plutôt pendant l'été à savoir
période la plus humide et donc ce qu'ils
ont constaté et bien c'est que les
dinosaures du grand nord du Grand Nord
sibérien de la fin du Crétacé pondez
tous leurs œufs à la fin de l'hiver donc
en fait leurs œufs se forment pendant
l'hiver ils sont pondus à la fin de
l'hiver et comme ça le comme ça les les
oeufs ont le temps de maturer enfin des
embryons à l'intérieur des œufs ont le
temps de maturer en fait quand le climat
est le plus clément ce qui paraît
logique si vous vous voulez garder vos
œufs au chaud c'est quand même mieux de
les pondre au début de au printemps on
va dire comme ça ils profitent de l'été
pour rester bien au chaud donc là on a
les carnivores ici en orange on a les
herbivores ici en bleu vous voyez les
carnivores pondent leurs œufs et très
très vite ils éclos et les petits
peuvent profiter de ici ce qu'ils
appellent la journée constante puisqu'on
est en très très haute latitude donc les
journées sont très très longues peuvent
profiter de cette période là qui
relativement chaude relativement
clémente pour grandir et multiplier
leurs chances de de survivre et les les
herbivores pendant ce temps-là et bien
ils peuvent garder leurs œufs au chaud
comme ils ne pouvait probablement pas
leurs œufs contrairement au carnivores
les carnivores on a des preuves qui
couvaient leurs œufs mais les herbivores
eux comme ils ne couvaient probablement
pas leurs œufs ils devaient les intérêts
sous des monticules donc eux ils
prennent puis ils sont plus gros aussi
donc ça prend plus de temps généralement
les animaux plus gros les œufs mettent
plus longtemps avec l'or aussi les cas
les herbivores eux pendant ce temps-là
bah ils entèrent leurs œufs en fait et
leurs œufs vont grandir comme ça à
l'abri d'un petit monticule de feuillage
qui va libérer de la chaleur et avec un
petit peu de soleil comme ça ça va les
garder bien au chaud vous voyez la
quantité d'informations qu'on peut
déduire de faux cils qui font cette tête
là
voilà c'est juste des petites danses et
juste des petits fragments d'os c'est
juste des petits fragments de coquilles
vous voyez la quantité d'informations la
finesse des détails biologiques qu'on
arrive à extraire de ces fragments de
ces fossiles extrêmement fragmentaires
des choses qui seraient considérées
comme du menu fretin en d'autres
circonstances et bien ces fossiles il
nous donne une image absolument
incroyablement bien défini de leur
biologie on arrive à reconstruire comme
ça des instants de vie à partir de
petits rogaton tout ça qu'importe si le
fossile est beau l'important c'est qu'il
réponde à une question et bah là c'est
un magnifique exemple on n'a pas besoin
de fossiles extraordinairement beau pour
répondre à de belles questions pour
donner de belles réponses à de belles
questions voilà et ça c'est beau et ça
c'est beau ça va être le le mot d'ordre
de cette vidéo je crois c'est et ça
c'est beau on continue avec les
dinosaures mais cette fois on passe aux
dinosaure moderne j'ai nommé les oiseaux
avec ce nouvel article paru dans cyan
advance qui est un article de génétique
génétique du développement donc on
quitte les fossiles pendant un petit
moment pour parler un petit peu et bien
de comment on transforme un poulet en
dinosaure
vous rappelez le projet chicken auxaurus
et ben ça n'a rien à voir avec
chickenosaurus mais il y a quand même
des gens qui travaillent à savoir en
fait comment les dinosaures se sont
transformés en oiseau et donc cette
équipe là c'est intéressant à la
transformation des écailles en plumes et
ici ils ont pris donc des pâtes de
poulet enfin des poulets donc ils ont
étudié les pâtes parce que les pattes de
poulet tout seul ça ne ça ne fait rien
du tout c'est mort mais ils ont étudié
en fait les pattes de poulet et comment
en fait un gène le gène sonic hedgehog
qui est donc Sonic le hérisson pour les
anglophones le gène que les
scientifiques ont nommé Sonic le
hérisson est un gène du développement
c'est un homéogène et il contrôle entre
autres en tout cas ce qu'ils ont
découvert ici c'est qu'ils contrôlent
entre autres la transformation des
écailles en plumes et en plus ce qu'ils
ont découvert c'est que sais pas quelque
chose d'extrêmement difficile en réalité
il suffit d'une seule injection au
deuxième jour du développement d'un truc
qu'ils appellent le smoothen agoniste ou
SAG pour faire plus simple donc le
smoothen agoniste injecté en une seule
fois au 11e jour du développement de
l'embryon transforme immédiatement en
fait agi sur le développement agit sur
l'expression de sonic hedgehog et
transforme immédiatement vos écailles en
plumes et ça c'est de la folie furieuse
parce que ça vous ça démontre en fait
avec quelle facilité on peut passer de
l'un à l'autre chez les oiseaux il y a
vraiment une plasticité au niveau de de
la structure des écailles qui permet
très facilement de passer de écailles à
plume de plume écaille dans le
développement alors c'est un article qui
comme vous le voyez est très long très
compliqué donc là je vous en donne
vraiment la substantifique moelle mais
je vous invite quand même à aller le
lire si vous vous en sentez le courage
pour comprendre quand même qu'il y a des
subtilités derrière ça mais la a décidé
c'est que c'est pas compliqué du tout
chez les oiseaux de passer de écaille à
plumes et donc on peut s'imaginer on
peut extrapoler à leurs ancêtres les
dinosaures en se disant peut-être que
c'était pareil aussi chez leurs ancêtres
les dinosaures théropodes on reste
toujours dans le thème chickenosaurus
avec l'équipe de Jack Horn un nouvel
article publié dans La revenue très
prestigieuse PNAS et donc cet article
nous parle de la transformation non pas
des plumes cette fois mais de la queue
en pigostiles donc le pigostil si vous
vous rappelez c'est la queue des oiseaux
donc les oiseaux n'ont pas une queue
faite de multiples vertèbres ils ont
toutes les vertèbres un peu coller tout
ensemble dans un petit moignon qui
s'appelle le pigostil qui est grosso
modo l'équivalent du coccyx pour un
humain voilà c'est pas exactement la
même structure mais c'est grosso modo la
même chose c'est la même philosophie
derrière c'est plein de vertèbres d'un
ancêtre qui avait une longue queue qui
est la queue ses raccourcis et le tout
c'est partenaires d'un espèce de
bouillie d'os qui est au lieu d'avoir
des belles vertèbres séparées vous avez
cette espèce de bloc d'os qui forme un
petit truc à la fin de la colonne
vertébrale juste après le bassin chez
nous on appelle ça le coccyx chez les
oiseaux ça s'appelle le pigostil et donc
ce pig hostile chez les oiseaux ne se
forme pas suite à une série
d'expressions de gènes extrêmement
complexes extrêmement élaboré non ce
qu'ils ont montré c'est qu'en fait le
PIG Austin se forme en réponse à une
inflammation c'est une inflammation
comme quand vous vous faites mal et que
vous avez une rougeur autour de cette de
cette blessure c'est une inflammation et
en fait où là comme par exemple
l'arthrose l'arthrose c'est une
inflammation des eaux et cette
inflammation des eaux quand vous avez de
l'arthrose provoque des
los se répand en fait en réponse à
l'inflammation l'os se répand de façon
un peu anarchique et du coup ça ça fait
fusionner entre eux des eaux qui
devraient pas fusionner donc ça c'est
l'arthrose c'est une inflammation
osseuse et bah en fait ce qu'ils ont
l'inverse c'est que chez les oiseaux le
pigostil se forme suite à une
inflammation mais déclenchée par le
corps lui-même pendant le développement
de l'embryon l'embryon se fait du mal
tout seul pour que les vertèbres
fusionnent ces trucs de malade c'est un
truc de malade donc l'embryon de poulet
qui a une queue je le rappelle les
embryons de poulet ont une queue à un
moment de leur développement ils
ressemblent très fortement d'ailleurs à
un embryon de crocodile donc ces
embryons de poulet vont se mettre à
sécréter quelque chose qui va générer
une inflammation et cette inflammation
va provoquer une arthrose forcée en fait
et le pigo style va fusionner et c'est
de la folie et c'est juste de la folie
et pour les grands fans du
chickenosaurus bah ça veut dire qu'il
suffit d'injecter de
l'anti-inflammatoire pour empêcher cette
fusion d'arriver c'est exactement ce que
vous voyez sur cette figure ci il suffit
d'injecter de l'anti-inflammatoire au
bon moment du développement
et pouf vous avez un poulet avec une
queue avec des vertèbres non fusionnés
donc en réalité pour faire un
chickenosaurus une des étapes pour faire
un chickenosaurus et bien c'est de c'est
d'injecter de l'anti-inflammatoire mais
ce qui est là où c'est hyper intéressant
en fait
réellement parce que tu que nosauses
comme je vous l'ai déjà dit plein de
fois c'est c'est même pas un rêve en
réalité c'est juste un prétexte pour
récolter de l'argent pour de la
recherche
la vraie réalité réelle de cette
recherche c'est que vous n'avez même pas
besoin de réprimer tous tous les gènes
qui sont impliqués dans la formation de
la queue en fait c'est à la base il
suffit de créer de générer cette
inflammation pour empêcher tous les
autres gènes de s'exprimer donc vous
pouvez avoir 1000 gènes impliqués dans
la formation de la queue d'un dinosaure
il suffit littéralement juste de
déclencher une inflammation au bon
moment du développement pour que tous
ces gènes la ferment la boucle ne
s'exprime plus et pouf vous avez un
pigostile donc un tout petit changement
qui déclenche une énorme conséquence
c'est le principe des hétérochronies de
Goulding je le rappelle une bonne
mutation une mutation au bon moment du
développement créer de grands
changements c'était ça les
hétérochronies de Gould et donc là là je
m'adresse évidemment à tous ceux qui
débattent les créationnistes les
créationnistes qui disent ouais mais
comment il peut y avoir tout un millier
de mutations qui vont qui sont
bénéfiques et vont toutes dans le même
sens bah non il y a pas besoin d'un
millier de mutations
une mutation au bon moment et pouf ça
suffit et ça c'est beau et cet article
donc nous le démontre magnifiquement en
nous disant et en plus en montrant que
l'inflammation en plus c'est ça aussi
c'est l'inflammation est un phénomène
embryogénétique on reste justement mais
dans les dans les arguments
anti-créationnistes avec un nouveau
gigantesque projet qui a été publié dans
dans la revue Science donc dans la revue
Science un nouveau gigantesque projet de
génétique qui s'appelle zonomia
plusieurs articles qui ont été produits
je crois qu'il y a une dizaine
d'articles qui ont été publiés dans la
revue Science il y a un volume entier de
science en fait qui est dédié à cette
gigantesque projet de génétique de
génomique en l'occurrence sur les
mammifères modernes donc ils ont réussi
à extraire plus de je crois il y a 140
génomes complets de mammifères donc la
différence entre une étude génétique
classique et une étude génomique c'est
que sur une étude génétique vous avez
que un ou plusieurs qui vont être ciblés
une étude génomique c'est une étude qui
se fait à l'échelle de tous les gènes et
aussi de tout l'ADN donc aux dents c'est
ça le une étude génomique on inclut pas
que des gènes que la partie exprimée de
l'ADN on inclut aussi tous les ADN nos
enfin toutes les parties de l'ADN qui
sont nos codants non codants et donc ils
ont inclus je crois 146 espèces donc
c'est la plus grosse base de données de
génome de mammifères qui a jamais été
produit ils ont notamment publié cet
article voilà une nouvelle échelle
génomique de l'évolution des places
internes ou en fait donc ils arrivent à
obtenir une horloge moléculaire qui a
beaucoup de données donc qui est très
très précise et grâce à cette horloge
moléculaire et bien il date l'origine de
tous les mammifères placentaires vous
voyez de la du milieu du Crétacé origine
des mammifères au milieu du Crétacé mais
là où ça change bon ça ça si vous avez
vu mes cours de mammalogie vous savez
que c'est pas nouveau l'origine des
mammifères placentaires profondément
dans le Mésozoïque c'est pas quelque
chose chose qui est particulièrement
nouveau par contre ce qui est nouveau en
fait c'est qu'au lieu d'avoir une
diversification de ces mammifères
modernes déjà à la fin du Crétacé en
fait vous voyez que ces lignes elles
restent relativement peu diversifiée
jusqu'à ce qu'on atteigne en fait le
Cénozoïque donc le Paléogène donc on a
une diversification des mammifères
modernes au Paléogène même si on a une
origine au Crétacé donc ça c'est
intéressant c'est nouveau et c'est
permis par justement la paléogénomique
et donc parmi ces études de génomique
que nous propose le projet zonomia et
bien il y a cette étude ici sur les
délétions spécifiques à l'être humain
donc ce qu'ils appellent des
hondel donc ça on dirait du on dirait du
chimiste donc les jondelles
bonjour à tous les chtimis qui me
regardent donc les jetons d'elles ce
sont des délaissions qui sont
spécifiques aux humains les délétions
qu'est-ce que c'est bah ce sont des des
morceaux d'ADN en fait qu'on a perdu
donc les morceaux d'ADN que les êtres
humains ont perdu on appelle ça des
secondaires et là où je trouve ça
fantastique en fait c'est que vous avez
les créationsnistes ils sont toujours en
train de nous dire ouais mais la
sélection naturelle elle enlève des
trucs et puis les mutations elles sont
tout le temps elles sont jamais
bénéfiques du coup l'évolution ça marche
pas et là on parle de délétion c'est à
dire des morceaux qu'on enlève
littéralement de l'ADN c'est des
morceaux qu'on enlève de l'ADN et
pourtant ces morceaux qu'on a enlevé de
l'ADN ont été bénéfiques au
développement de l'être humain est
notamment de son cerveau donc il y a
tout un paragraphe qui est dédié aux
effets neurologiques des scondelles et
si je condelle vous voyez ils ont des
ils ont des effets par exemple sur le
volume du cerveau sur des gènes qui
contrôlent le volume du cerveau donc on
a enlevé des parties du génome on a
enlevé de l'ADN de l'être humain et ça a
fait grossir son cerveau deux gènes ici
qui après avoir enlevé ces fragments au
final
agissent sur le développement du tube
neural chez les mammifères donc on a
après avoir enlevé ses gènes chez l'être
humain et bien le développement du
cerveau est devenu ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui là on a encore un autre gène
dont le développement dans le fait
d'avoir enlevé certaines parties à des
effets sur le cerveau et notamment sur
les capacités cognitives donc la
capacité à réfléchir donc on a tous
paragraphes ici de cet article qui dans
les sens nous dit on a enlevé de l'ADN
d'Homo sapiens et ça a ajouté de la
valeur à son cerveau
et ça ça les créationsnistes en PLS il
comprendront pas
donc voilà ça je vous en fais cadeau
enfin c'est le cesonomia qui vous fait
cadeau de cet article c'est un article
qui est très complexe je vais pas vous
le cacher il est très très long et très
difficile difficile à lire mais vraiment
ça cette partie là non c'est de l'or en
barre parce que vraiment tous les
créationsnistes qui vous disent
l'évolution ça enlève ça ne rajoute pas
bah là c'est vous enlevez de l'ADN et ça
vous rajoute du cerveau ça vous rajoute
des capacités cognitives et là tu fais
quoi
là sur le côté le créationniste
voilà je vous en fais cadeau merci zoo
Mia merci de nous avoir fourniss ce
magnifique exemple de d'évolution qui
fait marche arrière sur l'ADN mais du
coup ça peut faire marcher avant sur les
capacités cognitives on reste dans
l'étude de l'évolution génétique humaine
avec un article sorti maintenant dans la
revue Niger alors entre Niger science on
en a vu du beau du bel article
aujourd'hui franchement je me fous pas
de vous là on a vraiment vu du beau du
beau matériel donc on reste dans le dans
le beau matériel avec des des grands
auteurs des grands articles sur la
génétique humaine et donc ce nouvel
article paru dans Nature et qui nous
propose en fait que la génétique humaine
a été structuré de façon molle
en Afrique alors qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire que ce titre bizarre là une
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une structure
génétique molle en Afrique et bien c'est
tout simplement qu'en fait autrefois on
croyait qu'on avait une génétique très
fortement structurée à savoir une
origine pointée en Afrique de l'Est ça
c'était le scénario de base alors
certains avaient proposé l'Afrique du
Sud mais peu importe le fait est qu'on
avait vraiment une structure très forte
soit un noyau d'origine d'Homo sapiens
en Afrique de l'Est soit un noyau
d'origine d'Homo sapiens en Afrique du
Sud mais on avait vraiment une structure
avec un noyau
et en fait ce qui nous est dans cette
structure noyautée on va dire il y avait
eu des introgations notamment des des
ajouts de Gênes d'une population
archaïque vous avez certainement entendu
parler de ça qu'il y avait des
populations archaïques qui avaient
peut-être subsister pendant plusieurs
centaines de millions d'années et qui
s'était ensuite hybride avec Homo
sapiens en Afrique donc ça c'était ce
qu'on pensait mais en fait cette
nouvelle étude nous propose qu'en fait
non on n'avait pas on n'a pas eu une
population très structurée et ensuite
des des gènes qui sont venus de jeunes
CESU de population archaïques qui ont
survécu on sait pas trop comment ce qui
nous propose c'est qu'en fait on a eu
une structure très peu solide avec
plusieurs noyaux une structure en fait
où les échanges génétiques étaient
beaucoup plus fréquents donc on aurait
eu une génétique une une structure
génétique qui refléterait au lieu
d'avoir une origine soit un noyau en
Afrique de l'Est soit un noyau en
Afrique du Sud et bien on aurait eu une
structure génétique plus diffuse
panafricaine donc du coup c'est vraiment
toute l'Afrique en fait toutes les
populations africaines d'Homo sapiens
qui a presque tous les moments de son
évolution depuis
l'évolution génétique d'Homo sapiens on
peut la retracer jusqu'à 120 000 200000
ans donc c'est toute la structure
génétique d'Homo sapiens en fait qui
depuis au moins 120 à 200 000 ans serait
constamment en train de s'échanger des
gènes en fait donc ici ce qui vous
montre c'est un noyau sud-africain noyau
est africain un noyau ouest africain
pardon un noyau est africain qui
n'arrête pas en fait de s'échanger des
gènes alors que dans les précédents
modèles vous voyez là les trois modèles
qui vous sont montrés là on a quasiment
pas d'échanges en fait entre les
populations avant l'époque moderne donc
la toute dernière ligne que vous voyez
là où tout le monde baise avec tout le
monde là c'est c'est cette ligne là ça
en fait c'est c'est récent mais en fait
même avant ça du coup ce qui propose
c'est qu'on aurait une une racine molle
en fait c'est exactement ça ce que veut
dire le titre une
une une racine molle une structure
faible à la racine de Homo sapiens donc
on aurait eu cette racine molle avec des
échanges génétiques entre les
populations d'Afrique du Sud d'Afrique
de l'Ouest d'Afrique de l'Est et c'est à
cause de cette racine molle en fait
qu'on aurait l'impression qu'il y a des
gènes très anciens qui se sont baladés
qui se sont d'un seul coup injectés dans
Homo sapiens ce moderne en fait c'est
juste du polymorphisme c'est à dire
qu'il y a certaines populations qui
avaient conservé
certains anciens gènes et c'est juste
elles se sont juste échangées ces
anciens gènes c'est juste qu'on n'a pas
trace de ces populations aujourd'hui
quoi mais c'est certains populations
d'Homo sapiens modernes il y a pas eu il
y a pas eu de grands événements de baise
avec un avec un être humain archaïque
genre romanaledi par exemple donc il y a
pas eu de d'événements comme ça du moins
c'est ce que suggère cet article et donc
si vous vous rappelez bien c'est ce
qu'avait proposé cette origine
panafricaine d'homo à l'opposé d'une
origine
nucléaire quelque part en Afrique de
l'Est cette origine panafricaine de Homo
sapiens c'est ce qu'avait proposé
jean-Jacques Hublin et son équipe lors
de lors de la découverte du crâne de
jebelyrudo en tout cas lors de la
réattribution des restes de Djebel et
wood à Homo sapiens sarcaïque Jebel
Heroes les restes humains de jebelyrout
ils ont 300000 ans et c'est Homo sapiens
ce sont les plus anciens restent d'Homo
sapiens ce qui avait fait dire à
l'époque en fait que au lieu d'avoir une
racine d'Homo sapiens en Afrique de
l'Est une racine
nucléaire d'Homo sapiens en Afrique de
l'Est et ben en fait on avait une racine
diffuse partout en Afrique pas seulement
en Afrique de l'Est mais du coup j'ai
belirood ben c'est en Afrique du Nord
donc si on a Homo sapiens sarkaïque à la
fois en Afrique de l'Est à la fois en
Afrique du Nord jean-Jacques Hublin et
son équipe avait proposé que bah la
racine était plus diffuse la racine
était panafricaine on passe maintenant
aux autres mammifères donc on sort
d'Homo sapiens alors avant qu'on sur les
nouvelles découvertes sur les mammifères
je voulais juste vous mentionner au
passage que il y a un article dans
Science et Vie consacré à l'évolution
des mammifères et à comment ils ont
conquis le monde notamment à la limite
permit à Trias comment comment ils sont
passés d'un État où ils étaient dominés
par les dinosaures à un état où ils sont
devenus les dominants donc il y a tout
un dossier là-dessus dans le dernier
Sciences et Vie dossier auquel j'ai
participé donc voilà si ça vous
intéresse n'hésitez pas à y aller c'est
le dernier volume de Science et Vie
c'était la petite aparté self promotion
maintenant on repasse à la recherche la
vraie la bonne recherche celle publiée
dans Science pour changer de nouveau un
article dans Science nature et science
vous êtes vraiment très gâté ce mois-ci
donc cette nouvelle recherche parue dans
Science qui nous explique l'évolution
vers la méga herbivory vers le
gigantisme chez une lignée de mammifère
très connue qui s'appelle les
bron-touterre pas une famille de
mammifères très connue qui s'appelle les
bronchoter ou aussi connus comme étant
les Titans notaires il s'agit de
d'animaux herbivores relativement proche
au moins physiquement des rhinocéros ils
étaient proches par an des rhinocéros et
des chevaux etc ce sont des périsseaux
d'actiles donc c'est bon hôtel ils ont
vécu enfin ils ont largement dominé le
Rasis pendant les Hosn alors il trouve
leur origine au paléoscène et vont
s'éteindre à la toute fin de l'éosène
début de l'Oligocène et donc c'est bon
au terre ils sont caractérisés notamment
par cette tendance vers le gigantisme
c'est d'ailleurs les bron-toters qui ont
inspiré coupe a énoncé sa fameuse loi la
loi de kop qui dit que les lignées de
mammifères ça commence toujours petit ça
finit toujours gros c'est c'est ça la
loi de Cop à la base ça s'applique
surtout aux mammifères et ça dit que en
gros on commence petit on finit gros
alors il y a plusieurs explications à
cette loi de couple la première c'est
déjà c'est pas une loi c'est une
tendance évolutive c'est une règle
statistique mais certainement pas une
loi évidemment les lois n'existent que
pour être que pour être transgressé dans
la nature donc enfin dans la nature en
biologie du moins les lois on a bien
essayé d'énoncé des lois mais ça marche
jamais à fond mais bref le déjà c'est
déjà faut relativiser que ça arrive pas
si souvent que ça au final mais surtout
faut relativiser le fait que quand on
regarde l'évolution justement au cours
du temps ici la stratigraphie de du
poids du corps en kilogramme ici à la
verticale et bien on voit que au fur et
à mesure du temps certes il y a une
tendance très nette à augmenter la
taille du corps mais faut pas perdre de
vue que quand même à des moments il
existait des bron-toters gigantesques
certes notamment sur la fin mais il y
avait aussi des brouteurs de taille
moyenne qui flirtaient plutôt vers une
tonne et il y avait des gros taux d'air
plutôt de petites tailles qui flirter
autour de la centaine de kilos
voire même des plus petits que ça si
vous remontez légèrement dans le temps
donc la plupart des lignées en réalité
se diversifient en termes de taille la
plupart des lignées de mammifères
j'entends se diversifie en réalité en
termes de taille comme les chevaux par
exemple et puis et puis nous humains
allons focaliser juste sur les plus gros
en ignorant un petit peu les éléments
les plus petits et du coup on va rater
cette diversification pour ce focus
seulement sur les trucs qui deviennent
de plus en plus gros parce qu'on aime
bien ça quand c'est gros mais surtout on
aime bien quand ça donne des tendances
évolutives très nettes bon là chez les
prototaires on a quand même cette
particularité qui est que certes on a
une diversification en termes de taille
mais on a quand même une très très large
domination d'une tendance vers le
gigantisme
voyez que quand même le gros de cette le
gros de cette lignée là elle va quand
même vers le haut au niveau du poids en
kg ça va plutôt quand même largement
vers le haut donc ce qu'a fait cette
équipe
cette équipe ici c'est en fait tester
quels étaient finalement les moteurs de
cette de cette diversification slash
augmentation de la taille du corps et en
fait ce qu'ils ont déterminé ici grâce à
une phylogénie très très complète et
grâce à des outils statistiques c'est
qu'en fait les bron-totaires à chaque
fois qu'il y avait un événement de
spéciation c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois
que vous aviez un tronc commun d'une
d'un certain poids on va dire un tronc
commun d'animaux d'un certain poids qui
avaient l'occasion de se séparer en des
animaux légèrement plus gros et des
animaux légèrement plus petits en fait
systématiquement les bron-totaires
ne se sont pas dirigés vers l'état les
plus grandes ce qu'on attendrait d'une
tendance évolutive guidée par une loi
telle la loi de coupe mais en réalité
ils se sont divisés et systématiquement
les plus petits se sont éteints donc en
fait à chaque fois vous aviez une
division et les plus petits se sont
éteints et donc vous aviez deux nouveaux
une division et les plus petits sauts
sont éteints et ainsi de suite vous
donnant au final cette impression que la
tendance est essentiellement vers le
haut vers essentiellement vers des poids
gigantesques mais c'est juste qu'à
chaque fois que vous avez une spéciation
vers le bas mais en fait elle finit par
s'éteindre beaucoup plus vite que la
spéciation qui a eu lieu vers le haut
donc en fait il y a une il y a une genre
de voix de moindre résistance pour les
broutes en terre qui a lieu vers
l'augmentation du poids et ça c'est
logique quand on regarde la biologie des
animaux gigantesques les animaux
gigantesques et notamment les herbivores
ils ont des avantages non négligeables
sur les herbivores plus petits ses
avantages se sont déjà le fait d'être
plus gros vous avez un plus gros système
digestif vous avez donc une plus grosse
chambre de de fermentation et donc vous
avez vous vous pouvez extraire plus de
nourriture enfin plus de nutriments d'un
bol alimentaire équivalent donc oui vous
avez besoin de beaucoup plus manger
qu'un animal de petite taille vous
consommez en valeur absolue beaucoup
plus de ressources certes mais vous les
utilisez beaucoup mieux et ça c'est un
avantage non négligeable comparé un
petit animal
les animaux de grande taille aussi ont
certes beaucoup moins on certes beaucoup
plus besoin de manger mais en cas de
famine résiste beaucoup plus longtemps
alors que les animaux de petite taille
c'est des c'est des mobylettes quoi faut
leur remplir c'est des locomotives faut
remplir tout le temps sinon ça crève
très très vite donc vous avez quand même
une plus grosse résistance une plus
grosse résilience
à des changements à des variations
à des variations de la quantité de
nourriture les animaux de grande taille
notamment les herbivores sont moins
sujets à la prédation en tout cas une
fois qu'ils sont adultes donc ils
peuvent se reproduire beaucoup plus
aisément une fois qu'ils sont adultes il
y a très très peu de concurrence chez
les animaux de grande taille donc il y a
personne qui va venir vous embêter donc
c'est pour ça par exemple qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez les éléphants les derniers
représentants des promos Cydia sont les
éléphants ce sont des animaux de grande
taille et c'est une tendance qu'on voit
très souvent dans les chez les lignées
de mammifères les chez les chevaux par
exemple pourquoi bah parce que personne
vient les embêter là bas en fait dans
cette niche des animaux de grande taille
ils sont relativement tranquilles il y a
pas trop de concurrence non plus donc ça
c'est un autre des grands avantages
d'être de grande taille c'est que en
fait être de grande taille c'est pas
facile à faire c'est pas facile à
accomplir et du coup et ben il y a très
peu d'animaux qui atteignent ce point là
notamment chez les mammifères
l'extraordinaire l'extraordinaire
diversité des mammifères est faite
d'animaux de moins de 100 kg donc une
fois que vous avez dépassé la barre des
100 kg
vous êtes relativement peinard dans
votre niche écologique vous voyez dans
un grand espace écologique être de
grande taille c'est un coin qui est
relativement peinard bref donc être de
grande taille ça a plusieurs avantages
ça a énormément d'avantages et donc ce
qui s'est passé d'après ces auteurs avec
les bronteurs c'est que oui il y a eu
des tentatives évolutives de
diversification des Bretons terre vers
des espèces de plus petites tailles mais
à chaque fois elles se sont fait
éliminer et doux cette impression qu'en
fait on a une tendance évolutive quasi
constante vers les animaux de grande
taille
maintenant il y a une raison pour
laquelle la niche écologique animaux de
grande taille est une niche écologique
relativement peinard
c'est parce qu'une fois qu'on est de
grande taille ben on a quelques
problèmes
et notamment quand tu arrives Léo Seine
enfin la fin de l'éosène et le début de
l'oligosène vous avez la grande coupure
qui est un événement d'extinction qui
est dû à deux choses donc des migrations
d'une part donc il y a des espèces
notamment asiatiques qui vont se mettre
à se répandre dans le monde et à
concurrencer les autres espèces et vous
avez aussi une glaciation donc le début
en tout cas d'un refroidissement qui va
au final terminer en glaciation et cette
cette glaciation qui aura lieu à
l'oligosène donc vous avez un début de
refroidissement qui va terminer par une
glaciation et donc ce début de
refroidissement va voir les forêts qui
vont être graduellement remplacés en
fait par des savanes ou des steps donc
en gros il va y avoir une aride
aridification générale du climat avec
ces grandes étendues herbeuses qui vont
commencer à se répandre et donc tout ça
c'est des événements perturbateurs dans
la dans l'évolution d'une lignée animale
et en fait le problème c'est que quand
on est de grande taille
il y a des phénomènes physiques qui font
que vous avez très très peu de
répondants en fait assez des changements
climatiques et environnementaux
notamment quand vous êtes de grande
taille et ben vous devez vous avez des
temps de gestation plus long vous mettez
plus longtemps à devenir adulte donc
vous avez des temps de génération qui
sont beaucoup plus grands et on vous
êtes moins adaptable vous avez moins
cette possibilité justement grâce à la à
une nouvelle génération vous avez moins
de possibilités de brassage génétique et
moins de possibilités de nouvelles
mutations qui apparaissent donc vous
devenez sensible en fait à des
changements vous êtes plus résistant
dans un environnement stable vous êtes
plus résistant dans un environnement
généralement stable avec des petits
changements ponctuels on va dire des
changements comme je le disais en
abondance de nourriture ponctuelle mais
pas de longue durée par contre si un
changement qui se qui commence à
s'inscrire dans la durée c'est la
catastrophe parce que vous pouvez pas
évoluer en fait vous êtes coincé dans
dans un espèce de cul-de-sac en fait et
ça c'est dû à la taille c'est dû à le
fait d'avoir une taille géante et donc
c'est probablement ce qui est arrivé à
nos bons gros taux d'air donc voilà cet
article sur les bons hôtels il est
vraiment tout à fait fascinant et je
vous le recommande parce que du coup il
vous apprendra plein de choses sur
l'évolution des bredotaires et il y a
peut-être un poil plus facile à lire que
ceux de ceux qu'on a vu avant et on
termine ce Paléo news une fois n'est pas
coutume on va terminer avec avec des
vertébrés au lieu de terminer avec des
invertébrés on reste dans les mammifères
avec maintenant les cétacés alors comme
tout à l'heure j'ai parlé de fossiles
russes juste pour contrebalancer je vais
vous parler de fossiles ukrainien parce
que il y a encore de la recherche qui a
lieu à Kiev sachez-le moi ça m'a surpris
malgré du coup la guerre qui est en
cours là-bas les chercheurs Ukrainiens
arrivent tout de même à produire de la
recherche les paléontologues Ukrainiens
arrivent à produire de la recherche donc
celle-là elle est publiée dans un
journal qui s'appelle frontiers in earth
science c'est un journal relativement
jeune quand même donc il y a pas encore
une très très grosse réputation mais
c'est un journal qui est valide j'ai
publié aussi dedans c'est très très bien
c'est pas un journal prédateur et donc
ils n'ont pas de vertèbres de
basilosauridé du crâne donc des des
cétacés des cétacés archéo 7 qui ont été
découverts en Ukraine et en fait ils ont
passé ces baleines enfin c'est ces
autres baleines de basilosauridé au
scanner scanner à rayon X un scanner
médical pour étudier la texture de leur
OS et en fait ce qu'il trouve c'est que
les eaux des balises oridés sont
extrêmement denses alors que chez les
cétacés modernes les os sont plutôt
poreux et donc l'extrême densité des
eaux chez les basilosauridés c'est
quelque chose qu'on retrouve parmi les
animaux modernes notamment chez les
animaux qui sont semis aquatiques comme
les otaries ou comme les comme les
hippopotames par exemple donc des
animaux qui sont pas encore complètement
aquatiques
ce sont chez ces animaux là qu'on a en
fait cette texture osseuse très très
dense dans les côtes et dans les
vertèbres à l'inverse ou les spinosaures
par exemple on retrouve ça aussi chez
les spinos chez Spinosaurus en tout cas
à l'inverse les cétacés et les
ichtiosaures par exemple qui sont des
animaux complètement aquatiques eux ils
ont des vertèbres qui sont extrêmement
poreuses et alors chez les ictyosaures
je sais pas mais par contre parce qu'ils
sont plus vivants aujourd'hui mais par
contre chez les cétacés ça sert à
stocker de la graisse donc vous avez la
couche de graisse extérieure qui sert à
isoler le corps et ça c'est une couche
de graisse qui ne sert pas de réserve
par contre vous avez la graisse stockée
à l'intérieur des vertèbres et des eaux
qui elles sert de réserve ça sert de
réserve de d'énergie donc là par contre
la Grèce extérieure faut surtout pas y
toucher parce que si vous touchez à la
graisse extérieure bah vous crevez de
froid donc la graisse extérieure n'y
touche pas mais la graisse intérieure
stockée dans vos vertèbres ça par contre
on peut taper dedans et bien
basilosauridé n'avait pas de de graisse
intérieure du coup il n'avait pas de
réserves de graisse intérieure donc on
peut imaginer bon c'est cohérent avec
basilosauridé les basilosauridés vivant
dans la tétis c'est à dire dans une mer
relativement chaude mais aussi ça veut
dire s'il avait pas de réserve de
graisse intérieure ça veut aussi dire
que il avait une réserve de graisse
extérieure dans laquelle il tapait quand
il quand il faisait fin quoi quand il
faisait famille donc il se servait
encore de s'agresse extérieur donc ça
nous apprend sur le la physiologie des
basilosauridés et puis surtout ça veut
dire que basilosauridé les
basilosauridés comme basilosaurus tout
membres réduit qu'ils avaient je vous
rappelle que les basilosaures idées ont
des tout petits pieds des toutes petites
jambes donc ils retournent pas sur terre
c'était pas des animaux semis aquatiques
par contre ça veut dire que leur ancêtre
semi-aquatique était pas loin derrière
eux et qu'ils avaient encore conservé
finalement cette habilité si vous voulez
avoir les eaux très très dense pour les
maintenir au fond de l'eau après une
autre possibilité aussi c'est pas
forcément un reliquat phylogénétique ça
pourrait aussi être comme chez les
dugongs et les lamentins ou en fait ils
vivaient au fond de l'eau au fond d'eau
très très peu profonde et ça c'est aussi
cohérent avec le fait que généralement
les bases illusoridés on les retrouve
dans des anciennes mangroves dans des
anciens lagons donc dans des endroits où
l'eau était peu profonde donc les Dugon
JD les et les et les lamentins ce sont
des animaux qui sont complètement
aquatiques mais dont les ont sont hyper
denses comme ce basilosaider et ça c'est
parce qu'ils vivent dans des eaux peu
profondes et il se maintiennent au fond
de l'eau grâce à cette densité osseuse
donc voilà ça c'est les deux possibles
explications je crois que celles qui
préfèrent dans si je me rappelle bien
celles qui préfèrent dans cet article là
c'est l'explication selon laquelle il
vivait dans des eaux peu profondes mais
ça peut être aussi un reliquat
phylogénétique de leurs ancêtres qui
étaient encore semi-aquatiques ils
avaient pas encore perdu cette habilité
et vivant dans des eaux chaudes il
n'avait pas encore eu besoin finalement
d'avoir une couche externe de de graisse
pour les protéger du froid aussi vivant
encore dans des eaux relativement
tropicales je rappelle qu'on est allé au
sein à aller au sein il y a pas encore
eu ce grand refroidissement qu'il avait
pas encore eu lieu ce refroidissement
donc il faisait encore très chaud aller
au scène dont vous imaginez vivre dans
des autres tropicales aller au sein
c'était relativement
confortable et vous n'avez pas vraiment
besoin d'une bonne couche de graisse
pour vous protéger des eaux froides donc
voilà les deux explications qu'on peut
avancer d'après c'est d'après ces
fossiles Ukrainiens du coup et la
troisième chose c'est oui la
paléontologie ukrainienne n'est pas
morte voilà c'était Paléo news je vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi abonnez-vous
pour ne rien manquer d'ancien et je vous
dis à très bientôt
[Musique]